attacking chivalry as a set of social
codes has been the biggest cell phone
that feminism could possibly have come
up with it's been absolutely
catastrophic it's an incredibly stupid
idea
mary harrington welcome to the show
thank you for having me i spent a couple
of days in new york with a friend i'm
not around young children i don't have
any children at least ones that i'm
aware of and i
got to see
the
tyranny that is bedtime uh and
from my perspective you can tell me if
this is true right
to me it seems like a
daily game theoretic
litigative
negotiation
with a tiny drunk tyrant uh that happens
every single day on an evening at pretty
much the same time how accurate of a
representation is that
well
yes maybe sometime it depends a lot on
your child's personality and it depends
a little bit on how you roll as a parent
as well
um
what i mean by that is um
if you if you treat small children as
rational beings who need to be
negotiated with then you're letting
yourself in for a world of pain
but if you treat them as something a
little bit more like dogs that need to
be trained and i say that with love um
as a mother who really very profoundly
loves her daughter um and you start
doing that very lovingly and very firmly
from a young age you know with luck and
patience um you'll have a child who
likes a bedtime routine who's familiar
with it and who's when they get to a
point of tiredness just goes ah okay now
i'm in the groove now i know what's
coming next and they'll just chill out
and then bedtime becomes a relaxing
thing so it depends on a number of
different factors i mean also how many
kids you have you know if you've got
three then you know that harmonious sort
of twinkly
twinkly twinkly kind of thing isn't
quite so straightforward because they
all want different things and you know
my dear friend who has three under five
um
you know it's it's a it is a little bit
more like crowd control
um you know you've got one one screaming
for milk well the other one is um
throwing put or whatever you know
it's a different ball game but i think
but the idea the goal is
is to have a routine that everybody just
kind of falls into and you know where
you are with things and
and actually it's more like it's more
like uh
it's
it it's about training the unconscious
mind so that you can you can think less
about the stuff that doesn't matter you
know in that way it's like doing a cata
in martial arts
you know as is teaching teaching the
body to react instinctively and i think
that's very much that's very much the
approach that i'm in favor of when it
comes to very small children i saw the
group of three that you were talking
about i think that definitely
contributed there was a point we were
sat down sat down having dinner and i
think the oldest two had gone to bed and
then there was a
a point at which a
naked three-year-old just came sprinting
through the dining room uh and then
dived dive bombed onto the couch and
there's a mother sort of frantically
chasing after going i'm sorry i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry
it's so good but uh yeah i'm glad that
negotiating uh
or whatever it is the training i think
that needs to happen before there should
be there should be some sort of
onboarding prep school for that
yeah i mean it's it i guess in that
sense i'm quite old-fashioned you know
there are there are parents who take the
view that you know children children
will naturally spontaneously know what's
good for them in all possible respects
and you should just be guided by them
i'm not really i'm not really a believer
in that you know i'm very i'm very much
more classical in the view that you know
children have to be
habituated to the good and that's
actually part of your responsibility as
a parent and they'll still they'll still
be you know they'll do their best to
thwart you in every possible way and
some are more 40 than others um that's
very much a sort of thing
that's that's something that all
children can aspire to be to be thwarty
yeah they'll they all have their they'll
have their ways of being 40. but um
yeah i think it's it's your
responsibility to try and habituate them
to the good even if they don't
appreciate it at the time and even if
they don't realize it until like 25
years later you still have to try yeah i
think that's true that's all you really
can do given the fact that you spend a
good bit of time on twitter and this has
probably been one of the most intense
weeks on twitter ever what's your
what's your sense give me the aura
that's in the air
how apocalyptic has this week been
what's the shittiest stuff that you've
seen on twitter
i've been honestly i've been trying to
dial the noise down on the whole ukraine
thing on the basis that it's not really
in my wheelhouse it's not my area of
expertise none of us knows what's
happening on the ground because it's
just waltable propaganda from about at
least five different i mean i can think
of two obvious interest groups and
probably another three um less obvious
interest groups who've all got a stake
in skewing the story one way or another
and then and then you've got this
absolutely insane free-for-all of people
piling into different fandoms to just
treating it as a massively multiplayer
online role-playing game
and the whole thing is honestly just
doing my head in
because it's like the signal-to-noise
ratio is terrible
um and this and i have no i have no
useful contribution to make so i've just
been trying to keep your eyes down
someone told me thank you someone sent
me a big email with a bunch of stuff
about ukraine that was really
interesting one of them was
the current wikipedia article about the
ukraine russia crisis in february 2022
has over 20 000 words written in it and
more than 500 contributors now so you
are
literally live streaming a modern war
you know i'm seeing videos on twitter
like tick tock tick tock
apparently the ukrainian troops were
using grinder to locate where the
russian troops were at did you see this
i [ __ ] you not
yeah i mean there's something there's
something just so wild about that and
honestly deeply unnerving i mean i've
sort of
i set out to write a review of a woman's
written this memoir about raising her
transgender child and i sat down to
write the writer review of that book
this week um later this week um and i
ended up i ended up writing about um the
parallel universes that are formed in
digital culture because well let me
explain i mean for me you're probably
you're familiar with my writing you know
you're i'm sure you've you might my
views on my views on trans rights are
that they're not then well they're it's
complicated it's a difficult issue that
needs to be approached sensitive
um and
it's
and reading reading this book which was
obviously very sincerely written by a
woman who loves her daughter lost her
child very much indeed
really really wants to do the right
thing um
it was like going down
it was just like diving feet first into
a completely parallel universe um you
know a lot of the same talking points
that i'm familiar with for reference but
with completely completely antagonistic
interpretations on them you know but the
same
the same sets of facts but carefully
curated to tell a completely
contradictory story it was completely
disorienting it was like being in the
upside down
um and i and i read through this whole
thing i found it i had to start
take a few breaths every every few pages
and just think
she believes this
as completely and sincerely as the
people as the people who pit themselves
absolutely against her do you know
everybody really really believes this
certitude on both sides yeah completely
and there's no there's no reconciling
these two points of view
it's absolutely the the contest is
absolutely zero sum and i don't know
where you go from there and i was
thinking well you know this is this is a
serious enough thing when we're talking
about the bodies of children
you know that's actually what's at stake
in in that particular
set of internet culturals there's the
bodies of children in the bodies of
adults as well but you know where where
the rubber really hits the road and
where the flights get really bitter is
the bodies of children and then you
think well you know and then you then
you scale that up to the bodies of
civilians in an entire
national international conflict and you
know then then you're then you'll see
that you're really you know that that
escalates the intensity of the fandom
and it escalates the
the
the bitterness of the cultural war to
just an unimaginable degree
um
and i honestly i i don't see
i i don't see how that can be resolved
yeah and i've been i've been watching
the watching the temperature go up and
up and up this week and thinking you
know never again am i going to wonder
how it was that the entirety of europe
named itself into you know massive into
a world war in 1914
because that's that's kind of what
happened at that point and it feels like
that's that's you know unless we take a
few deep breaths and step away you know
and a lot of people step away from the
keyboard and touch grass that's what
we're going to do we're going to meme
ourselves into international nuclear war
and that's [ __ ] terrifying
it's people spending too much time too
much time on the internet so i went to i
went to a meet-up in austin uh this
weekend you know who scott alexander is
from astral codex 10. yeah so he he held
a meet-up in austin and he sent that out
to his entire mailing list which is
probably not
too far off half a million people and
obviously a very very very small number
of those in the states that are in
proximity to get to austin or whatever
but i met i met a guy who spends eight
hours a day in virtual reality i met
people that are
uh moderators of 4chan moderators of
uh moderators on reddit board you know
people like real real internet people
and um
yeah it's it's so fascinating to think
about what happens when you go
web first into life
uh and the externalities and the the the
assumptions that people have about how
they're supposed to live
yeah
yeah i mean i i guess that's a theme
that recurs fairly often in my work
um it comes up a lot for me because i'm
probably the last generation to have
grown up in the before times
i'm 42 which puts me right on the cusp
of of the internet or really the social
media age which is where it where it
went supernova you know i mean there
were nerds who were on the internet for
a good 20 years before i was but you
know we got our first online connection
when i was in 1997 i think when i had my
first email address at university so you
know i can remember actually doing
research in libraries i went all the way
through school without even a mobile
phone i remember them four times it's
completely different world
um you know i know i know there are
thoughts lots of people who are sort of
nostalgic for the 1990s because you know
culture was a thing then i don't know i
could
yeah i have a few things to say about
that but but it was it was completely
different um and
there's been a there's been this weird
sense of
like some things have just stood still
since the internet arrived you know we
don't really have teenage subcultures
anymore for example as far as i can make
out yeah i mean if there are teenagers
out there you can correct me on this
what do you mean
well well but like i was i was a boss i
was an email in
right okay yeah
you see you know what i'm talking about
um but like you know but in the before
times you know like what you need for a
teenage subculture is like it's the
right alchemy of boredom and sexual
frustration and a limited social sphere
and um
and very various factors like that and
then a lot of spare time and not very
much mobility or puppet money
you know and you need all of those
things to make it to make it come
together
um and if you can find your people just
like that just by searching then
you don't ever you don't ever end up
with the sort of you know the
the happenstance collection of misfits
that creates a that that's the sort of
spark you need for a teenage subculture
to have why
in a place why well
i mean if you think about
like that they're all they're all very
banned by place like the subcultures as
they emerge they they start out very
sort of place bound
um i mean geographically
yeah geographically i mean manchester
united which you you may you probably
remember and you know the punk thing in
the 1970s was that was all that was all
the angry council estate kids in
yeah
in
grumpy grumpy industrial towns you know
not really seeing much much of a future
and not seeing much of the much of the
good life
um and you know seeing seeing the 1960s
turn sour on them you know they're all
they're all very banned by place and
location and then it becomes an
aesthetic and then it becomes
commercialized and then it sells out to
the man and then there's this cycle
which sort of you know i remember you
know which starts accelerating you know
from the from the 60s onwards you know
that that line in in with nail and life
which i'm sure you've seen
you know the film with now that i no
you've never seen that film no hold on
oh it's it's a oh it's a it's a richard
e grant um and paul mcgann um from the
mid-1980s absolute cult classic um all
about all about these two um
completely completely disreputable
failing actors at the end of the 1960s
um who
who spent a weekend in penrith with with
one of their
one of their heterostatic uncle oh i
mean you have you have to see it but i
mean it's about it's about repression
it's about the end of the 1960s and it's
about your subcultures falling apart and
it's about whether you know the meaning
of force selling out to them it's a it's
a great thing it's an abs but there's
this there's this line right at the end
where where
danny their drug dealer says they're
selling happy hippie wigs in woolworths
now
you know the greatest decade history of
math has
[Laughter]
and we have failed to paint it black is
that the death knell do you think of a
movement if it gets featured in like if
there's a wh smith's end end of aisle
stall
with a cardboard cut out of whatever it
is
well yeah if you think about it you know
think about think about what this is
what the cycle time is now between
something appearing on the internet and
the being merch of it like it doesn't
even have time to go through a sort of
buyer's a product buying process to get
into woolworths you know there were
ghost of kiev t-shirts on in in etsy you
know within 48 hours saw the
tea towel of a [ __ ] russian ship
exactly
exactly
you know when but when they when the
cycle between meme that the sort of meme
to merchandise cycle is like less than
48 hours
um there's there's no there's no space
in which a culture can even a subculture
is he can even emerge let alone sell out
okay and because
as soon as you start to commercialize
something
much of this seductiveness about the
movement has been taken away because
it's not subversive or cool or niche
anymore is that the reason that it did
it shortcut yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and i mean like cool like a
subculture will start out being of being
a cool group of kids and then the the
people just people start jumping on the
bandwagon
and then you know more and more people
will pile in and then eventually they're
selling hippie wigs in woolworths yes
that's how it used to work in the four
times but the cycle just goes too fast
now yeah it's direct from meme to
woolworth's
yeah yeah yeah and that within 48 hours
so they're just i mean you know and i
don't know what what once honestly i
think the closest thing we have to use
subcultures now is ticks like tick-tock
induced
uh tourettes
and and emoji pronouns and stuff like
that
sorry have you ever did you hear have
you heard about this so i've heard i
know i know
about pronouns on
twitter but i don't know what yeah
you're making me feel mary you're making
me feel like the biggest boomer ever
i'm 34 years old and i'm being made to
feel like a [ __ ] boomer
yeah i should i i clearly need to touch
grass clearly it's you it's you that
you're speaking to here so what what's a
tick tock ticks and what's an emoji
pro this is this is a this is an article
that helen lewis wrote recently
at the atlantic at least i think she
certainly did i think she's written an
article about it and there's been the
tourette's clinics all over all over the
place are seeing an epidemic of a new
variant of tourette's which doesn't seem
to have the same etiology as classical
tourettes which can be treated with
antipsychotics but that seems to be
being caused by the internet
you know people people are coming in
like kids they're usually they're
usually teenage girls and they're coming
in with often
with exactly or more or less exactly the
same ticks as um influencers with
tourette's on social media
what was that have you ever seen or is
it ever been described what this sort of
tick is because i can't imagine what
that would be
they'll they'll you know they think like
saying saying particular a particular
word i can't i can't remember an example
but there's some random stuff like you
know saying cucumbers spontaneously in
the middle of a sentence or or you know
falling to their knees and waving their
hands you know just odd sort of gestures
or spasmodic ticks
um and and girls appear to be especially
teenage girls appear to be catching this
off influencers who display those
symptoms on tick tock
[ __ ] me so this is like some sort of uh
mimetic modeling
of
high status social behavior at least
within one particular niche
that's been delivered through
social media oh my god and i think i
mean this is probably this is probably
the closest we have now to use
subcultures
what's some sort of parasitic
psychological contagion that gets girls
on tick tock to do
like i know duck faces spontaneously out
of nowhere
i mean it's not massively different to
the ice bucket challenge really is it
the ice bucket challenge was conscious
this appears to be subconscious
anyone that tips a bucket of ice over
their heads subconsciously they have
that's a that's a serious tick
right right but but what my point is my
point is it's still a beam
and it's still
and it's transmitting through the same
the same vectors and to a degree with
the same for
to the same ends
i don't know i mean those sort of weird
esoteric corners of the internet where
people mutter about the fact that these
means are in a sense alive and
independent of us but you know i don't
really want to speculate about it people
don't have ideas ideas have people
yeah i mean that's a i wouldn't be the
first person to contemplate that but you
know you watch you watch something like
this rip through impressionable
populations and you think well you know
maybe there's something to it and then
you watch
you watch an entire you know
an entire international population of
social media addicts you know seemingly
memeing themselves into you know
thinking that maybe nuclear war wouldn't
be such a bad idea and you think well
actually it's not just ice pocket
challenges yeah and it's not just but to
them
to them the externalities of talking
about this stuff is basically the same
talking about because i mean
i mean i think they're just not really
thinking about it you know there's a
whole class of people who were like yeah
yeah we should lock down and it didn't
actually make very much difference to
them
you know and i'm sure you know somewhere
in the lizard brains they're assuming
that ricardo is still going to be
delivering groceries after nuclear
armageddon and then they haven't really
thought it through
what [ __ ] the bed
yeah i mean that's that's about where i
am this week you know you said what's
the vibe i'm like apocalyptic it's a
it's
it's a blend of sort of nihilism
sort of a apocalyptic cassandra complex
and apathy which is nice which is a nice
place to be actually i think let's talk
about i want to talk about this war on
relationships that you've been thinking
about the last few months for me i've
been completely submerged in
evolutionary psychology and looking at
trends in dating dynamics you might be
familiar with vincent haranam uh who has
done some stuff for quillette alongside
rob henderson who again like here's my
here's my [ __ ] advert for rob
henderson everyone needs to go and
follow him on twitter because he's like
one of the best people on twitter um
talk to me about this war on
relationships what's that
um well i mean it's my my mo is always
meme first ask question later and i
started i started saying war on
relationships before i'd really come to
come to the decision about what i meant
by it
um
and so when i talk about the war on
relationships i'd like to be clear i'm
not just talking about um
the breakdown of relationships between
men and women um i mean it's uh my
working hypothesis is that's kind of
that's about where we are with it right
now but it opens out to a much more
wholesale
war on our ability to on on spontaneous
interpersonal social reactions which are
not mediated by the market i mean that's
that's quite a long thesis which i
remember writing up as a book chapter at
the moment before the book which
hopefully will come out towards the end
of the year if i can shamelessly plug
that here it's called feminism against
progress you'll be back on you'll be
back on to talk about that so we'll
we'll shill it multiple times
i'm really excited about it it's
absolutely it's a it's a wild ride
writing it but yeah i mean the like the
current chapter i'm working on is the
one about the war on relationships which
which to my mind is about it's about
destroying um organic interpersonal
relationships between people
um
except those which can be mediated
through the market and commercialized
what's an example of that
um
well i mean actually
and that's that's really where the the
relations between men and women you know
serve as a very powerful example um
because
it seems to me that there's a
there's a fairly concerted effort to
discourage men and women from just
meeting and falling in love you know
when
women could be encouraged for example to
offer their services on only fans
instead and monetize monetize men's
desire
or
um everybody could be persuaded to sign
up to dating apps which um you know
increa you know encourage a sense of
endless optionality and stop people and
you know discourage anybody from ever
actually falling in love and getting off
the dating apps because the grass could
always be greener on the other side
um you know
it sort of it d it unplugs um
the human longing for connection from
other humans and plug and and orders it
instead to limit capitalism you know
with the kind of rewiring of all of our
basic desires you know
to for
in the interests of profit i mean that
probably makes me sound like a
completely unhinged um anti-capitalist
sort of you know alex jones type looney
but but this is
once once you start seeing the war on
relationships you you can't answer it
yeah like pretty much every
every facet of
public policy
effectively served to support the war on
relationships
um because every
everything which was banned
came under the heading of spontaneous
interpersonal
interaction
um and everything which was somehow
which somehow made exception for came
under the heading of human human
interaction which in some way serves the
market so you know going to church was
bad you know go free free [ __ ]
children's playgrounds were closed
singing together was banned you know
visiting your family in groups of more
than a small number was banned but
somehow you were still allowed to go to
the office and somehow you know you were
still allowed to go to shots and somehow
you know for a long threat you know on
and off you were still allowed to go to
pubs you know the only the only context
in which you were allowed to to continue
interacting with people was where money
was whether there was a credit card
involved in some form or another and
everything else was shoved online
um which again you know serves you know
serves to monetize in one form or
another whether it you know whether it's
zoom making the money or
i don't know
or only fans or whatever
and you know zoom replaces family
get-togethers and only fans replaces you
know whatever it is that young single
people do on friday night
and so suddenly you're in a situation
where all all kinds of domains of
spontaneous interpersonal interpersonal
relationships have been
have have been methodically destroyed
and reordered to the market
um like it probably makes me sound like
a tin foil hat but that was that that
for me was the that's the story of of
what the pandemic did i don't i don't
think of it as a deliberate conspiracy
but in practice that's what happened so
that really and the sort of macro scale
is what i'm talking about when i talk
about the war on relationships
what's this korean untact policy thing
oh my [ __ ] god pardon my language but
oh my god
this is a south korean policy which has
accelerated over the course of the
pandemic which seeks to remove eliminate
all human contact in the interests of
increasing productivity so automating
shops
automating libraries
um
just removing removing any any messy
frictional situations where people are
involved in interactions with one
another in you know just turning
everything into a sort of
hyper-mechanized set of vending machines
in the interests of also they say
increasing productivity you know i mean
it strikes me that they haven't really
thought it through because
humans have some basic needs
and which include other
humans um but i i i suspect that a lot
of a lot of people who come up with this
stuff you know believe very firmly as do
as do a lot of progressives that there
is no such thing as human nature and
that in fact we can just be remodeled um
you know either to serve the greater
good or to serve the interests of profit
or you know perhaps those two things are
the same thing whatever you know that's
that's all just hope it turns out for
the best rory sutherland says that uh
silicon valley sees everything as an
optimization problem and you said this
to me
three years ago and i can't stop
thinking about it and it's not just
silicon valley it's that
rather than looking at it from a
human-centric perspective it's presumed
to be some sort of engineering problem
where if we can just get the right set
of parameters and deploy them into the
world then all of the problems that
we've got can be fixed when you realize
that the human brain is
wholly irrational and the more that i
learn about it the less and less that i
feel like i have conscious control over
anything free will discussions aside the
fact that i'm just whatever rider with
blindfolds on the back of an elephant um
makes me think that you know when you
when you are talking about this if
you're talking about increasing
productivity and yet
making someone go into this completely
sterile petri dish of a supermarket and
maybe not have their one conversation
per day that they might have with
somebody which would be the person
behind the checkout then leads to this
person killing themselves in two years
time because they've never had any
intimate contact or any human contact
with anybody you go
it's it's far too reductive to think
that this is an effective policy and yet
because we're in this world where we no
longer pray at the altar of human nature
or of religious ideology
the technological revolution has
presented us with a new god that can fix
all of the problems that we have in our
lives and if we follow that forward you
just think well it's just a
technological problem it's simply an
optimization issue where if we get the
right logistics and the right parameters
set
everything's going to be sorted
and it's not true
it's not true you know people people
can't just be rewired like that
i mean
i don't know maybe maybe if you set
about you know conditioning people over
the course of several generations you
know perhaps you could perhaps you could
have some effect but you know what sort
of monster would love what sort of
monster would do that i don't know i
mean maybe we're in the process of
finding out
the koreans apparently i've got this
quote i absolutely adored this quote
from you in one of the articles the
consequence of liquefying all courtship
rituals and sexual norms wasn't a
feminist paradise of non-exploitative
sex but endemic intimate violence and a
multi-billion dollar porn industry but
the utopians believe so firmly that
human nature doesn't exist that the same
thing keeps being tried what did you
mean by that
just that really um yeah i mean a
recurring theme
um in
idealistic efforts to break down
existing norms
um which i mean you can you know one way
of looking at existing norms might be
you know the sort of the
simplified stories we tell our children
in order to make sure that humans don't
keep making the same mistakes
again
you know you could
nice simple heuristics you know you
teach your child to go to bed regularly
because you know you learn you've
learned from experience as i have
um that you know if you go you go to bed
at the same time every night it just
saves you a lot of hassle you get enough
sleep you feel good you know it's not
rocket science but you can't explain
that to a one-year-old so you you just
you just train them like a dog to go to
bed regularly and then hopefully they'll
carry on
when they get to adulthood and i mean
you know that's a that's in in microcosm
that's just what that's all traditions
are really
um and you know sometimes sometimes they
need to be junked if they just don't fit
the conditions anymore you know if
you've got traditions that apply to
living in the desert you know 3 000
miles away that just don't really make
sense in a temperate climate then you
know maybe maybe you need to rethink
them but you know traditions like going
to bed regularly uh going to bed at the
same time every night you know they
still work possibly
why did
why was it that the feminists the the
paradise that they were looking for why
did that not come about
honestly i think they i think they just
had a
well i mean that's a that's a very big
question um
fundamentally i think are there are some
irreducible differences between the
sexes which are just not taken into
account i mean this is you you should
talk to louise perry about this you know
how she's her books coming out and i
don't have you had louise on no who is
she
oh she's a great friend of mine another
another reactionary feminist i don't
think she'll i don't think she'll uh
hate me for describing her that way um
or or adjacent anyway she's she's got a
book coming out called the case against
the sexual revolution which is a
feminist book
and it's the feminist take-down it's a
feminist critique of the sexual
revolution which
she argues very cogently from
evolutionary psychology amongst other
things has been a disaster for women
because fundamentally men and women you
know at scale want slightly different
things
um and they always they prioritize
certain different things you know that
might not always be the case you know
and i mean as she put it to me the other
day her view is that you know on the at
the individual level the differences
between men and women are not that great
but at scale they're big enough that
actually you need to you need to
you need to treatment slightly
differently can you give me an example
well let's think
um are more violent let's go
you know i mean i'm married to a very
lovely man he is not a violent man i
dare say you're not a violent man you
know most men i interact with on a daily
basis are not violent men um but at
scale men are more violent
you know something like 97
99 of all sexual crimes are committed by
men you know most of the most of the
murderers in prison most of well most of
the prisoners full stop amen
um you know
i'm sure you're familiar with all of
these statistics you know and it's not
it's not an accusation against you or
any other individual man to point out
that men are more violent
and so and and because of that it does
it it makes sense for example to treat
male and female prison populations
different
you know that that opens out into a
whole you know there are a whole whole
series of minefields we can we've been
walking through there yeah well you owe
me when i want to but but just uh just
to keep the
keep the thing on
on why why the sexual revolution didn't
work um it's because it was premised on
the idea that men and women are
basically the same apart from some sort
of trivial kind of topographical
differences
but it's just not true
and it's definitely not true when it
comes to sex you said in a different
article similarly chivalrous social
codes may feel condescending but men are
still statistically physically stronger
and more violent than women an assault
on codes that encourages men to restrain
their physical dominance may not wholly
be to woman's advantage so that's the
fact that we can say i don't need a man
to open the door for me we don't need to
have this sort of power dynamic in a
relationship typically
however when you roll the clock forward
and say okay what happens if you erode
these and you get rid of these you
realize well maybe the second and third
order effect of this was that it was
constraining some of the more malignant
parts of
men's is that is that what you're saying
exactly exactly i mean in my i'll put it
much more strongly since i'm since i
might as well might as well have a go at
getting cancelled this week i've had two
or three two or three attempts already
um i think i think attacking chivalry um
as a set of social codes has been the
biggest cell phone that feminism is one
of one of the one of the most savage
cell phones that feminism could possibly
have come up with it's been absolutely
catastrophic it was an incredibly
[ __ ] stupid idea and it was it was
brought about
by a bunch of women who
who was who felt safe enough doing it
because they were they were fairly
fairly civilized fairly privileged and
they were confident that they could
demand that the men in their lives would
treat them well and they didn't think
about they didn't think about men and
women in different social contexts who
maybe needed us a
clearer and more simplified set of
guardrails and they specifically didn't
think about how much more vulnerable it
would make the women
in you know perhaps you know among
people who
who need a simple set of guidelines are
you talking about maybe the difference
between a middle and upper class versus
a typical working class environment
well i mean it's not it's it's obviously
over simplistic to
to to break down you know educational
achievement you know to say that always
invariably maps onto cognitive ability
and educational achievement and you know
impulse control and so on and so forth
but there are some correlations um and
when you're talking i mean the sort of
the sort of free-for-all and you know
everybody should just you know be
themselves
um
edit which which is great you know
amongst a bunch of you know
young
university graduates who sort of who've
been broadly brought up with decent
manners and told and taught to go to bed
regularly on the same time every night
you know it's a completely different
ballgame to people who for example you
know to have poor impulse control and
you know not very much education or
grown up in a violent or traumatic or
impoverished family you know who have
who have a history you know have a
history of interpersonal violence
already and you know saying saying to
somebody like that or you should just
follow your heart as a you know is going
to produce different results
and if you then say oh and you and you
don't need chivalry if you don't need
codes of chivalry which says don't you
which don't which say don't hit women
you no longer need those and in fact
it's it's it's feminist to get rid of
the codes which say men shouldn't hit
women then it's not going to produce the
it's not going to produce a good result
well presumably they didn't mean to get
rid of um
explicitly get rid of don't hit women it
would have been don't hold the door open
but are you saying are you saying that
downstream from that that's that was the
inevitable conclusion that you got to
well i mean you know
i'll dodge that very slightly by saying
by by pointing out that you know choking
and intimate violence is now normalized
during sex
was that by feminism
well so certainly the you know sex
positivity has been has been mainstream
feminism since the 1980s so actually
yeah
you know and there are there are bitter
ongoing turf wars with the you not not
only um
within within feminism today about uh
whether or not you know
whether or not to what extent
interpersonal violence and you know how
how that maps onto consent and you know
you don't whether don't yup yum is
really enough
to
i know
whether that's really enough to to
account for you know the ways that the
ways that an intimate encounter can be
abusive without being non-consensual you
know it's very it's very volatile
terrain
and and i think a lot of the one of the
many reasons it's become so volatile is
that there just aren't any rules anymore
and to a significant extent there aren't
any consequences
in the sense that you can have the most
degrading sexual encounter but as long
as you use birth control chances are
nothing nothing permanent will come as a
result of it
so that was
oh okay so you're saying that
part of the sexual revolution you had um
physiologically the decoupling of having
sex from making children and then
culturally also you had this decoupling
of
the sacredness around sex the
lack of none
but virginia ironside
who's a
a journalist who a long-standing
journalist you know was was in her 20s
in the 1960s and she wrote a few years
ago about what that was like and she and
she said that prior to the pill it had
been possible to say no to somebody
coming onto you because there was always
a risk of pregnancy but
i'm trying to i can't remember the exact
quote you said well armed with the pill
it was basically it was easier sometimes
to just have sex with a man out of
politeness to make him go away because
they knew they knew you were on the pill
and so i mean what other reason did you
really have to say no
and so
oh wow
so the implication
or the male ego
had one
fewer
self-justifiable or excusable reason for
why men could have to swallow their own
pride around this woman doesn't want to
have sex with me because
wow i never even thought of that you um
it made it orders of magnitude more
difficult to say no to loveless or
degrading sex because it could now
potentially be constant three so there
was no there was no longer a material
reason for a woman to hold out for a
loving long-term relationship
um and i'm i'm with louise on
questioning whether the long-term
consequences of this have been overall
have been overwhelmingly positive for
women
that is wild i never thought of that
before you uh i heard you talk about the
statistics the relationship between
abortion and shotgun weddings as well
yeah i mean that's one that's one the
catholics are very fond of um it's a
counterintuitive relationship but but
it's it's fairly well documented
that in fact um
the immediately after abortion after
contraception became conception then
abortion was legalized um well the
number of the number of abortions went
up and you would expect with
contraception now widely available you'd
expect the number of abortions to go
down but in fact what that wasn't quite
what happened because um you sort of
have to think of it as a difficulty of
scale you know there was just more there
was just more sex happening
because because it was theoretically
consequence-free
um and so even though the number of even
even though the number of sexual
encounters that resulted in accidental
pregnancy was lower and there were so
many more of them that the absolute
number of accidental pregnancies went up
did you follow yeah yeah and then there
was an implication for the man's uh
requirement to stay around because it
was seen as
yes can you explain that
exactly and and also because it was now
possible to go and get an abortion if
you were accidentally pregnant the
social pressure on men to then step up
uh went away
um so so there was no longer an
obligation on there was no longer an
expectation that if a man one woman
locked up um he'd be expected to marry
her because the pregnancy was much more
or the birth sorry was much more her
choice
exactly exactly so so because it because
ending the pregnancy was now an option
um it was it was that similarly meant it
wasn't it was much more of an option for
men to walk away
these two things blow my mind they
absolutely blow my mind this is like
rory sutherland's level stuff where he's
talking about oh well here's the first
order effect and maybe you can see half
of the second order effect but rolled
the clock forward five to 10 to 25 years
and you have this externality that you
had no idea was coming and it's
completely terrible
absolutely and i mean it's you know what
what we do with these conclusions i
don't you know i don't really have a
firm view on that um you know i have i
have friends who are very firmly
pro-life you know i'm i have
i wrestle with it um i think it's a it's
an incredibly complex and incredibly
fraught issue and i'm and i'm also i'm
also of the view that once a material
change is there um you know just saying
we need we need to put this back in its
box um is is very rarely enough you know
because once the technology is there
people are gonna want to use it
um and and i think
yeah i think just saying we should put
this back in its box may or may or may
not actually have have the desired
effect um but you know but i do think
it's absolutely incumbent on us to think
through what the actual second and third
order effects have been of these
absolutely monumental technological
changes because in in my view and the
sexual revolution is is on a pile of the
industrial revolution you know in and in
a sense actually wendell berry the
american writer
describes describes the the consequences
of the sexual revolution as being a kind
of industrial industrialization of sex
you know they are reordering a
reordering of sexual intimacy um along
to the same parent to the same
industrial paradigm
you know suddenly it was open to the
market
i found a very i found a very
a telling detail and the same year that
hayek um was arguing about you know the
spontaneous about the markets just you
know the spontaneous order of markets i
think that's the phrase spontaneous
order and what was the first
was also the first um anti-pornography
conference organized by andrea walken in
new york
um
and i i just think it's fascinating that
you know while this guy is holding up
this idealized picture of markets as
this spontaneous self-organizing force
right at the other end right you know
somewhere else in the picture somebody
else is is waving a placard and saying
no actually there's this market which is
uh which seems to be happening
spontaneously and we really don't like
the order which is which it's bringing
in
talking about the sexual revolution then
you speak about uh i don't know whether
it's an anti-sexual revolution or it's a
sex negative position that we're sort of
finding ourselves falling into
can you explain that well i don't really
i don't really think of myself as i i
don't really see the arguments that i
make as being um sex negative at all
i mean i've
i made a i made a process argument
against um
against being public about your kings on
the basis that you just enjoy them more
if they're private
um and the moment
you know the moment you start parading
your your disgusting proclivities
through town you know they start they
start seeming flat and boring and you
have to find something even more
disgusting to get the same thrill and so
i mean if you're going to i mean some
people some people are going to have
some people people like what they like
right
um but and i think you know the the way
to keep that free song of the forbidden
is a healthy dose of depression that's
that's the only way to keep it feeling
forbidden that's one of your is is that
one of the dynamic the porno dynamics
laws
the three laws of polar dynamics yes
yeah the there's what was it the the law
of fap entropy yeah the law of fab
entropy can you explain what the law of
pap entropy is for people
that's you know that that's really that
that's the law that says you know
whatever it is that you start out
wanking to is going to is going to start
seeing what seeming boring and you'll
have to find something yet more
disgusting
um to get the same thrill which is why
it doesn't you know people can make all
the arguments they want to about ethical
porn but you have to see if porn is a
vector you know it's a it's a direction
not a not a series of not a static thing
and and you know you can start an
ethical porn but you'll be you'll be
down there in the down there in the
sewers watching blueberry porn before
you know it
it's a thing don't even ask don't google
it really don't google it okay okay okay
so yeah anti-anti-sexual revolution i
think that you mentioned about you're
seeing increasing numbers of sort of 17
18 19 year old
um people girls especially who are kind
of withdrawing from a hyper sexualized
world you have a friend i think who
took all of her bikini photos down from
instagram and wouldn't post photos where
she's got her shoulders out and stuff
like that and that seems like almost
puritanical you know compared with
what's typically been put forward in
popular culture for young people
absolutely and i mean i should i should
underline the fact that this is very
subcultural at the moment but my my good
friend catherine d um also known known
on the internet more as default friend
has been tracking this for a few years
you know she writes a lot on internet
fandoms and sex and relationships and
she's been she's been tracking the the
rise of sex negativity particularly in
young women for for years um but it's
and
in a nutshell young women have just had
enough you know especially the girls who
went through the tumbly years where it
was all done don't kick shame me and
then just found themselves in these
violent and abusive encounters which was
supposed to be fun just weren't and
there was no discursive space in which
to say no actually this was disgusting
and upsetting and i don't ever want to
do it again because it's like oh i don't
know and you know if you're going
through you know but there was one i
mean it's it's been it's been deleted
since but there was a horrific a
horrific series of tweets that some some
young women i mean she was only in her
early 20s and this had happened to her
you know some time before as she was
saying you know i
i
i had a relationship with this guy like
you you know he was a dom you know but
you know i woke up i woke up one day to
find him you know i sort of came came
back to consciousness one night to find
him shelving brushed up adderall into my
cup you know this is supposed to be sort
of you know kinky stuff but but just
what is that
right exactly
exactly
you know or you know
he wanted to experiment with breath play
so he got steaming drunk and put me in a
rear naked chokehold and i passed out
you know that's that's not that's not
fun for anyone you know i don't know
what's going on there but that's not fun
and that's somebody who's gone a long
way down the porno dynamics rabbit hole
and is just you know needs to get his
kicks somehow um but then and and sort
of has perhaps kind of lost sight of the
fact that that's a real human person
that he's doing it to because
i mean you hear horror i mean again
don't google this but if you ever want
to see you know what the the suffering
this causes to men
um it's you know you don't have to spend
very long on the nofap forums
um to see to see you know that some of
these guys are really struggling with it
i mean i i salute every single one of
them for trying because it's
you know
they've had their sort of dopamine
receptors hacked by this stuff sometimes
for years and that and they're trying to
they're trying to keep the habit and
it's an extraordinarily difficult thing
to do
you know when your brain has been
rewired by it to the point where you
know you
you can't get off except in a very you
know in a particular from a particular
angle whilst thinking about something
incredibly
baroque um yeah you've got to do some
sort of mental jujitsu mindfulness
exercise in a desperate attempt to put
yourself in an aroused state
yeah yeah yeah yeah and this is this is
well documented you know this isn't just
this is an anecdotal this scene this
happens a lot um and these and these
guys and once you're once you sort of
you know once you sort of ranked
yourself into that kind of a paralysis
you know you you can't have an intimate
relationship with somebody not really
you know until you've got yourself until
you've rewired your brain again because
i mean how are you ever supposed to be
intimate with another human being
you know if you can only if you can only
get off while sort of standing on your
head and thinking about blueberries
yeah i think it's i think it's
horrendous i think i think it's
absolutely monstrous
so rolling rolling the clock forward
from there are you do you think that
we're going to see more of this
i i don't know what you would call it
like an anti-sexual revolution or a
re-uh
sacrificing of the intimate relationship
or is that what you would prescribe if
you were to try and fix it
i sincerely hope so but it's not it's
not a simple problem to fix and i think
you know in as much as i mean it's
already happening um
i see it already happening but it's it's
subcultural and it's generally coming
from what i what i would call young
counter elites
by which
uh who's that yeah
kids who are in their twenties i'd say
probably
um you know young younger millennials or
gen zed
and who who don't buy into the whole
mainstream thing
who don't who don't
who aren't fully signed up to the
integrating that's what wesleyan calls
the integrated vertically integrated
messaging operators you know and who who
read whatever it is who who sort of
i i don't want to call them conservative
because they're not exactly conservative
um
i don't know quite what they are
and they're their own thing but but but
those those kids some of them
are thinking this stuff through very
concretely you know some some of the
conclusions they come up with are
frankly terrifying well then you know
i'm not i'm
i'm not even going to go there like i'll
i'll write about i'm not doing that on
the podcast so i'm getting okay okay
um
but um
but again you know i'm not in their
shoes so you know what plus one guy what
can i say really
if i was there maybe i'd be i'd be
forming the same views
um but yeah i think i see i see you know
young younger sort of countercultural
people you know taking taking very firm
views on this and being unlocked i don't
know it's sort of
among among that cohort i see it sort of
going in two directions you know people
either go radically you know they are
they either go full nuclear war on
relationships you know there are various
different ways you can do that you can
go you can go full on hedonistic
um you can go all out for the you know
the victory of one sex over another you
know you sort of girl boss only fans
five or
alternative you know the pickup artist
thing is another there's another variant
on that it's just about you know
instrumentalizing defeating and you know
symbolically humiliating the opposite
sex you know to me that seems to be the
kind of you know
the the
the principal mood you know and you're
you're more interested in kind of
keeping the score with respect to your
male friends than you are
you're sort of
interacting with the human and i think
you know there are there are males there
are male coded and female coded versions
of this in my observation you know the
the girl boss only fans
thing is
is is in a sense you know just a mirror
image of the people artists thing it's
adversarial right it's taking the
primary
uh typically the primary source of value
that the opposite sex had
and then weaponizing your ability to
manipulate that so men weaponizing their
ability to get women's bodies and women
weaponizing their ability to get men's
resources
yeah yeah yeah and it's
i'm finding it really really striking
that
um there are
you can find almost exactly the same um
comparison you know
exactly the same attacks on marriage in
feminist writing as in in cell and
pick-up artist
writing they all they're all they all
hate marriage they all see it as no
better than prostitution i think it
should be replaced with a more with a
franca and more more more market based
in fact version of exchange there we are
we're back at the war on relationships
you know in in a sense that sort of you
know
this this effort to to break down any
possibility of solidarity between men
and women
um and replace it replace it with
something that's transactional and
instrumental um and can you know and you
know can be ordered you know to the
logic of you know wages
or or commerce or
you see as you see it as you say coming
from both sides you know it's it's older
than it's older than social media you
know
i would
it's probably older than the sexual
revolution or they definitely
accelerated with the sexual revolution
and i sort of feel like we're reaching
some kind of an end
some
i honestly don't know how much worse it
can get
without the human race just just sort of
losing losing the ability like without
us all just losing the ability to talk
to one another or you know form families
full stop that was the that was the end
point so the last time that i was stood
here in austin i was having a
conversation with a guy called vincent
haranam who i mentioned twice today and
i'm going to continue to
force-feed traffic to him in the way
that he precisely doesn't want to have
happen he is the most pseudonominous man
i've ever met and yet i'm gonna continue
to get people to go and look at his
stuff um
and the end point that we came to he's
done a big deep data dive he's a data
scientist that's looked at the um
relative attraction rates what's
happening on dating apps so on and so
forth
and the outcome really is pretty
terrifying especially when you look at
the um population projections
uh but not just in the west now as well
like china's in a pretty good place a
pretty bad place with this as well too
but there's not a very
positive rosy outlook the apocalyptic
way that we started talking about
twitter at the beginning
looks
uh paradisal in comparison with the
future for relationships i think and um
i remember reading this article from uh
kat rosenfeld i think she's called and
she was i think you've spoken about this
too which is
in order to make something attractive
and um for there to be excitement in a
relationship there needs to be a little
bit of uncertainty and a small amount of
uh
danger might be the wrong word but at
least a little bit of uncertainty and
some sort of play between the two people
and there's two things that are going on
at the same time one is this complete
liberalization of don't kink shame me
and at the same time this sort of
equivalent of helicopter or snowplow
uh
not parenting but uh sexual norming to
the point where you get this consent
pawn and i learned recently that there
is a push for a blockchain of consent
which would be able to track
every single
degree of consent that you would be able
to tumble down so you have these two
uh sort of diametrically opposed but
parallel um
dynamics moving at the same time in
order for me to
get most people to get excited you're
going to need some degree of uncertainty
and excitement and play between the
relationship and yet at the same time
you have this helicopter situation where
any
slight discomfort needs to be pushed out
of the way
uh and you mix that in with the
pornification of everything and access
to
only fans and women being able to
commodify men and men being able to
sexualize women and
it's not good it's not good
what do you think we should do chris
the only solution that i've come up with
is
putting marriage back up on a pedestal
um
i think that you're going to struggle to
pull women back from the
very recently acquired position of um
equity
in society uh you know
by 2030 you're going to have two women
for every one man at a four-year us
college on average at the moment between
the ages of 21 and 29 women earn 1 11
pounds more per year than a man all of
these sorts of things and you have this
hypergamous nature which is obviously
kind of like the thing that the
manosphere like gets its kicks off
it's increasingly difficult for women
that are raising up through their own
competence hierarchy to find a man that
is equally or more competent than them
because
young women are outperforming men in a
bunch of different domains at the moment
so
and also saying girls you should settle
for less
like that that meme is not going to take
hold telling girls that you like joe
schmoe is the guy for you but if you
make it less about the partner and less
about the commodification of that less
about oh what's their
instagram follower count or what sort of
car do they drive and you make it more
about well i want somebody that is able
to provide that's going to be a good
father that's going to be a good member
of my
uh my extended family too that my
parents are going to like that's going
to be reliable like that institution of
marriage was what wrapped that up and
made it something
beyond just the quantifiable metrics of
success and i think that you can that's
the first part the first part is to
negate some of the hypergamous nature
that that women have and rightly so they
want to find the right man for them um
by making it slightly less about the
man's quantifiable metrics of success
and um much more about the institution
of family relationships so on and so
forth and then jeffrey's big romance
big romance precisely abolished big
romance yes exactly we need to get rid
of it just nuke it um and then jeffrey
miller the evolutionary psychologist one
of the guys that did all of his all of
this stuff in dating dynamics he told me
that
you can hack hypergamy in a really smart
way in the bedroom and also around the
house by just doing role play he said
that the human brain and this is
something that makes complete sense you
don't need to have
an actual power differential in a
relationship all the time because you
can fake yourself into believing that
there's one there you know if you've got
a the high-powered boss [ __ ] phd
half a million woman with a man who is
the lower owner in the household and yet
you flip that polarity in the bedroom
the human brain doesn't really know it's
not like oh this is just a game that
we're playing it doesn't really know so
you can use those tricks so those would
be my two uh
more power play in the
power play in the bedroom uh to flip
hypergamy and then the re-um
pedestrialization of marriage as an
institution those are my solutions what
do you think
yeah i agree i mean i have a i have a
whole probably completely unprintable
thesis about why why bdsm has been so
has become so popular
but i think it's a sort of
it's it's an involuntary uh
it's an involuntary backlash against
being too much quality between the sexes
in fact people just like a power dynamic
and you can't you're not going to be
able to get rid of that and the more you
repress it the more appealing it becomes
you know this is this is one of the laws
of porno dynamics isn't it you know
every ever every taboo has an equal
opposite category of porn and
at the moment the the the moment the
moment you make you make power dynamics
that the moment you make you you put
equality on the pedestal you know i mean
what what do you think is going to
happen in the bedroom people are going
to sexualize our imbalances and so it's
going to feel taboo and forbidden yeah
right so the more the more egalitarian
society becomes the more the more kink
the more the more kinky people's sex
lives are going to be and i think i
think we just need to embrace the fact
that you know power dynamic people just
like power dynamics and we ought to lean
into them more and we should just make
them real and we should do it without
safe words but lovingly
properly
what's your solution
no i will not elaborate i mean i think
we should abolish big romance i also
think we need more single sex spaces for
both sexes and i'd actually lean harder
into that for men for women
i think one of the most disastrous
things that's happened that's happened
to men in the last three or four decades
is that the number of phenomenal spaces
where men can be men together without
the company of women whose god has
really shrunk now i mean i can't speak
to that from in a first person sense
obviously because i'm a front hall
person um but
it's it's very clear to me thinking
about my male friends and just just from
observation and from listening to
listening to men speak it's just obvious
there aren't very many you know unless
you unless you're on a football team or
you know
unless you unless you play a sport or
you know there are there are some
limited other contexts which will
probably still be mostly male or all
male um there just aren't there aren't
very many places where where men can
talk amongst themselves without without
women and that that seems that seems
like it could be a problem to me because
i mean i have no idea what men talk
about amongst themselves but it seems
right to me that that that should be a
thing
um and it's possible you know it seems
it also seems likely to me that there
are there are kinds of social encounter
and kinds of communication which are
going to happen in that context which i
have no idea about um but which are
probably quite important to men and if
you don't do you know if those things
aren't there then you know men are going
to be sad you know this all this none of
this seems to me like it's rocket
science um and you know my observation
just looking at the numbers is that men
are sad at the moment
you know the suicide rate has never been
great and it's getting worse
um
you know men men men are not doing men
are not doing great at the moment
um and you know if if we want good
husbands you know that's that's an issue
for women as well it's an issue for
everybody it's a human issue
you know if we're if things are
you know and i'm sure i'm sure somebody
will come along be like oh you know
she's all like oh what about the men you
know women suffer as well yeah of course
of course that's true but you know the
so
pain isn't a pie you know one person
does one one group doesn't get less of
it
one one isn't yeah so one group isn't
deprived of suffering and status just
because another group is suffering as
well you know it's not
there isn't
suffering really isn't a limited
resource
yeah the zero sumness of suffering that
i mean that's that's exactly what what
you see
when you try and have this discussion
online you know
it's it's
this is your job right to mimify
everything but you would be able to
create a flow chart of the way that
um discourse moves forward when somebody
tries to put forward either women are
suffering or men are suffering um and
with the men are suffering one it's
typically something to do with in in the
mixer would be um i thought you just
needed to man up bro sort of um small
dick energy or you need to you need to
get your act together uh and then
this is uh just a rehabilitated so
asking for male 1 new space is this a
rehabilitated version of excluding women
from powerful conversations that men
just want to have again it's like really
tropey and every time that you see
somebody do this online you can predict
what's going to be the pushback and you
go well this is why we're not actually
making any genuine progress towards
anything because it's just the same
horseshit arguments just like
spat out every single time you know if a
hand if the price
of reducing the suicide rate across
working-class men
is that a small number of female
barristers and ceos get excluded from
the old boys network i'm okay with that
you know i think there's a class
dimension to this which often gets left
out and
and the the women who are being who are
pushing for entrance entry to all of the
old boys networks you know it's kind of
you know arguing very cogently from
their own economic interests but you
know that the subset of women who are
barristers and ceos and goal bosses is
relatively small and the subset of men
who are you know just people with jobs
and women who are just people with jobs
is considerably larger and if you if you
break down single sex spaces in the
interests of you know of the elite
and in the process destroy important
social spaces for everybody else then
i'm not sure that's a good trade-off
and i i think that's one we could
usually look at again
you talk about this to do with the
number of women that want to be
stay-at-home moms versus those that want
to work and those that are in the middle
that want to have a blend between the
two as well
yeah um i mean that's uh
that that study is actually it's a it's
20 years old so i hope somebody will
come up with something more recent but
this is catherine hakeem's a sociologist
did some research into what we can
actually want given the choice when it
comes to work
um and
according to her findings there are
maybe 20 who who really just want who
really want to be mums they want to be
in the home and maybe 20 who really want
to be girl bosses and everyone else um
kind of would would like a nice mixture
of these i mean anecdotally when i think
of the you know fairly normally
middle-class moms who kind of my social
circle you know at school pick up with
me or whatever that's true
you know
there are some who work full-time but
most of them would quite like to have a
relationship with their children and see
them for more than an hour once a week
um
you know most
most most people don't have careers they
have jobs you know both sexes
you know there's a ver there's a small
minority you have careers you know under
willing to trade off the amount of time
they spend with their kids in the future
their career but most people most people
have jobs and you know there's some bits
of little fun and some of it some bits
of it suck and they quite like spending
time with their kids as well you know
it's again it's not rocket science it's
quite common sense i'm not saying
anything which ought to be controversial
at all
what was the
insight
that you explained to do with
how the uk government
pushing their primary
um women where here for you policy to be
more assisted child care
was playing into that it was to
basically encouraging women that uh
their primary role should be in careers
yeah i think it was i seem i seem to
remember that at the last election you
know when it came to
when it came to offering something to
women every single one of them all three
of the major political parties you know
competed for how much more child care
they could offer
you know nobody nobody offered for
example to extend maternity leave or
you know there was some talk about you
know making paternity leave more
flexible which i support even although i
i think uptake is a bit patchy on that
but perhaps that's a that
perhaps that's a medium-term cultural
change thing i don't know
um but yeah i mean the the the reflex
you know which is perhaps understandable
from from the kind of women who become
mps you know if you think about the sort
of personality type who's going to who's
going to end up in
elected to parliament anyway um is the
the assumption is generally that that
what women need is more child care
um
and it's it's considerably rarer amongst
mps to find somebody who's willing to
stand up and say well what if mothers
actually want more time at home with
that child what if some mothers want
more time at home with their children
when they're young i'm pretty much the
only person the only mp i've seen who's
willing to who's willing to stand up and
say that or even come close to saying it
is miriam cates
is a i forget she's she's conservative
and peace one of them needs awards i
think um but she's she's really an
outlier on that and pretty much
everybody else is just all you know that
they're full-on goal boss it sounds
primitive right that's why
but why
well because that's how it would be
interpreted by the press what are you
trying to do are you trying to re-enable
uh women's ability or the um
their predisposition to be seen as
purely mothers that their role is just
to give birth to women and then make
sure that the dinner's on the table at 6
pm that's the unsophisticated way to
look at it
i mean
one pushback which i i doubt you know
i'm not going to put in the words in the
mouth of miriam cates because i don't
know what she'd say to this um but but
again you know i mean you say that like
it's a bad thing you know what's so bad
about doing i've been a stay-at-home
mother it's great life as long as you
get on as long as you have some enough
funds and you get on with your spouse
being a stolen mum is really nice you
know it's i mean you're your own boss
like you know really what's not to like
you know
i struggle to understand why anybody
would want to
would think that's terrible i'm with you
um
but that's just but that's not how it
gets framed i mean you know again i'm
here i am here i am working i sort of
started by accident now here i am
so it's complicated you know i sort of
fell into doing something that i loved
and now and now here i am
but
you know but
it's one thing it's one thing making
sacrifices for a career that you love
um and you know with with the help of a
supportive partner
um and it's another thing altogether um
you know being being offered more child
care by the government so you can spend
eight hours rather than six hours a day
putting packets through a scanner in a
supermarket
instead of seeing your children you know
but
yeah i i just i just struggle to see
how you know
i'm not convinced that every woman in
that situation would see that as doing
them a favor
i guess is what i'm saying you know
maybe there are other possibilities too
mary harrington ladies and gentlemen
people want to check out your sub stack
and follow you on twitter which they
absolutely need to do where should they
go
um look me up at reactionaryfeminist.com
or yeah or search that on substitute
you'll find me there
reactionaryfeminist.substance.com
i'm moving circles on twitter it's this
has been fun thank you for having me
it's been really really great i'm
looking forward to the book coming out
if you can hurry up and write it please
uh that would be great i need to get
some sleep and get on with it tomorrow
war on relationships
i'm looking forward to it thank you very
much mary what's happening people thank
you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace